we condemn
president putin and the russian
federation
for their unprovoked
illegal
attack and invasion of ukraine
we stand with ukraine we stand with the
people of ukraine
and we stand with canadians here at home
with ties to ukraine
we must use all of the tools available
to us as a country
to defend ukraine in europe against a
vicious authoritarian onslaught
one of the things that canada can do to
support democracies in europe
is for this government to recognize that
canada
is an energy
has immense energy resources
is to recognize that energy is vital to
canadian and european defense and
security
to recognize that natural gas is
consistent with environmental goals in
the transition to non-emitting sources
of energy and to undertake new measures
that ensure natural gas pipelines can be
built and approved to atlantic tidewater
if we can build pipelines to get
canadian natural gas to tidewater we can
displace russian gas in europe
thereby countering the threat from the
russian federation and president
vladimir putin and strengthening
democracy in europe and here at home in
canada
parliament certainly stands to condemn
vladimir putin for their unprovoked
illegal attack and we certainly stand
with the people of ukraine
but what i find
really disturbing and appalling at this
time
is the crass exploitive attitude of the
conservatives to try and take a
humanitarian disaster and use it to
promote the pipe dream of spending
billions of taxpayers dollars on
pipelines they could have talked about
the need for parliament to stand
together to take on russian
disinformation they didn't do that they
could have talked about the food crisis
we're starting to see if we uh see wheat
exports in ukraine cut off they could
have talked about refugees but they're
not interested in that i expect a lot
for many of the conservative
backbenchers but i expect more from this
member
does he not know that quebec has already
shut down lng pipelines so if he's going
to get to tidewater does he not have a
map of canada because quebec says it
will not allow lng exports because it
actually undermines our world
obligations to reduce greenhouse gas
emissions it is clear
it is clear as understood by the
european union that energy is not only
vital to economies it's vital to defense
and security and that's why the
conservatives have introduced this
motion today because it is vital that we
protect the security and defense of this
country and that of our european allies
and partners
let me be clear madam speaker russia's
actions are as deplorable as they are
unacceptable to us and to the
international community
and they indeed may amount to war crimes
under international humanitarian law
which is why we stand together with
other nations referring this to the
international criminal court to
to actually investigate to see whether
war crimes are already being committed
as
my colleague has stated
we will continue to stand with the
ukrainian people and our response has
been strong and it has been
fast
every day we have responded to the
requests of the ukrainian people and the
ukrainian government every day we have
done the things that are meant to
suffocate the russian economy and to
isolate them in the world
madam secret is extremely important that
we continue these important efforts and
not be distracted
not be distracted by other issues we
keep our eye on the ball and ensuring
that we are doing what president
zielinski and the russian government and
the ukrainian government has requested
of us to put that squeeze to suffocate
the russian government this is the way
russians will understand what their
government is doing in their name and
call upon the russian government itself
to stop as well
what
president zielinski has not asked for
is are more pipelines in canada
what president zielinski has not asked
for is a retreat to 20th century energy
policies
what president zielenski has not asked
for is us to engage in a debate this day
about
climate change or about uh oil security
what president zielinski has asked us is
to be laser focused on the problems of
ukraine and to allow
them to have our support on every
critical aspect that they need support
on
i am deeply concerned that the
conservative party doesn't get that
while i absolutely
appreciate their solidarity on our
actions that we have taken
what distresses me greatly is a crass
opportunity that they are taking like an
opportunistic infection
to take advantage of a deeply disturbing
grave international crisis that affects
every one of us in this house every
canadian and everyone would this member
acknowledge that his calling an
infection the the conversation around
energy security which relates to food
security which relates to to poverty
reduction which relates to all of these
very important subjects is misguided and
needed in to ensure that the world has
has peace and security both in ukraine
going forward and
i have to allow for other questions i'm
going to give the benefit of the doubt
here to members from all other political
parties that have seemed to think that
this is somehow about a a a big oil
vendetta well mountain speaker the
reality is is that uh the the the energy
security situation in europe is has been
funding the war in the ukraine and now
it is a high time for us to acknowledge
the fact that we need to ensure that
there are ethical sources of energy that
that that do not go into the hands of
despots but specifically will this
member acknowledge that it's not simply
oiling oil it is the the the ingredients
that are required for things like
fertilizer which with a upcoming growing
season in the ukraine madam speaker will
be absolutely essential for ensuring
that the people of ukraine cannot just
have energy security but long-term food
security as well
the cynicism
the exploitation
of the using a humanitarian disaster to
promote once again the interests of the
oil sector
i'm actually appalled i know that
there's many on the conservative back
bench who would take that position
without even blinking but i've always
had great respect for the member for
wellington halton hills not to play such
a stunt at this time in our history
because this motion could have talked
about the need to deal with russian
disinformation
and a strong position by our parliament
we would have supported that
we could have talked about the need to
help
in visas and the refugee crisis
is clogging the polish border and all of
us could have stood together as a
parliament and supported that
we could have talked about the growing
food crisis that we're facing as
ukrainian is one of the world's bread
baskets and the crisis of that war and
what it means for global food supplies
but the conservatives aren't interested
in that
because the conservatives
fundamental view of the world has always
been to take as much public money and
blow it on oil and gas even though oil
and gas is making enormous profits but
they want the public to pay for it so
now what they've decided is when there's
a humanitarian crisis
well that's another good reason
for them
to shamelessly
promote something like this
i'm actually embarrassed madame speaker
that as the world is looking for
solidarity and a vision of democracy and
freedom and rights that we're here
having to play games
of promoting the interests
of oil and gas once again in a petrol
state like canada